[موسيقى]
نعم حسن قبل قليل ال طائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه قصفت منزلا ماهونا بالسكان
لعائله الكاظمي بالقرب من المسجد الشافعي
في منطقه المعسكر غرب مدينه خانيونس ما
وصل حتى هذه اللحظه الى مستشفى ناصر هي
جثامين ثلاثه من الشهداء بالاضافه الى عدد
من المصابين نتيجه القصف الاسرائيلي الذي
استهدف هذا المنزل في ساعه متاخره من
الليل المواطنون اتوا الى هنا الى مجمع
ناصر الطبي في ظل انقطاع الاتصالات وشبكات
الانترنت اتوا مشيا على الاقدام حاملين
عدد من الاصابات واخرون اتوا عبر دراجات
الاريه ينقلون الاصابات في ظل الوضع
الخطير الذي تشهده هذه المدينه مع استمرار
الغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه وايضا القصف
المدفعي الكثيف الذي نفذته قبل قليل عدد
من دبابات جيش الاحتلال المتمركزه في
منطقه المحطه والكتيبه اتجاه عدد من
المناطق في وسط مدينه خان يونس وسط تحليق
مكثف للطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وايضا
لطائرات الاستطلاع على ارتفاعات منخفضه
ايضا في منطقه وسط القطاع لازال القصف
المدفعي يستهدف مخيمي البريج والمغازي في
وسط القطع وبشكل كثيف مع استمرار
الاشتباكات على الاطراف الشرقيه والشماليه
من هذين المخيمين بالاضافه الى القصف من
ال وارج الحربيه لمنطقه قرب دير بلح والان
يتجدد القصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي على عدد
من المناطق في وسط مدينه خانيونس كما
تسمعون دوي هذه الانفجارات اكثر من ع
قذائف حتى هذه اللحظه خلال الدقائق
الاخيره اطلقتها دبابات جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تجاه عدد من المناطق في وسط
المدينه التي تشهد ايضا اشتباكات في
محيطها بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منذ ايام المقاومه
تستخدم الصواريخ المضاده للدروع وايضا
العبوات
الناسفه لمنع تقدم وتوغل الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه بالاضافه الى استهداف القوات
الراجله الاسرائيليه التي تتحصن في عدد من
منازل المدنيين في منطقه البلد وسط مدينه
خان يونس مع استمرار الغارات والقصف
المدفعي الذي لا يتوقف خلال النصف الساعه
الاخير على الاقل
طيب ما سمعناه قبل قليل من
انفجار كبير قلت بانه واحد من الانفجارات
التي تسمعونها الان في
وسط خانيونس ما الذي يستهدفه هذا القصف
واين بالتهديد وطبيعه الاحياء التي يتم
قصفها بهذا الشكل العنيف في هذه
الاثناء نعم حسن
قبل تقوم الدبابات الاسرائيليه بهذا القصف
الكثيف من قبل الدبابات تجاه منطقه وسط
خانيونس منطقه البلد على وجه التحديد
سمعنا قبل نحو ساعه من الان سماع دوي
انفجار كبير في تلك المنطقه ويبدو انه
ناجم عن تمكن المقاومه الفلسطينيه من
تفجير احدى الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
في تلك المنطقه تبعها عدد من الغارات
الجويه في تلك المنطقه وايضا قصف المنزل
في منطقه المعسكر قبل قليل والقصف المدفعي
يتركز على المنطقه التي سمعنا منها دوي
الانفجار الكبير قبل نحو ساعه من الان ما
يؤشر الى وجود اشتباكات بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
فتستخدم قوات الاحتلال الدبابات
الاسرائيليه لقصف المناطق التي من المحتمل
ان يتواجد بها مقاومون بالاضافه الى غطاء
جوي من قبل الطيران الحربي الذي يستهدف
هذه المناطق بعدد من الصواريخ كما ذكرنا
قبل نحو ساعه من الان اذا يمكن القول ان
هناك اشتباكات تدور بين بين المقاومه
وقوات الاحتلال في اي وسط قلب مدينه
خانيونس
نعم حسن الاشتباكات تدور في في محيط منطقه
البلد في وسط مدينه خانيونس هذا المحور
اشتعل مجددا خلال الساعات الاخيره بعد
تفجير احدى الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
في هذه المنطقه سبق اشتباكات وسمعنا دوي
اطلاقات ناريه كثيفه في منطقه قيزان النجر
ومنطقه بير عيه الى الجنوب الشرقي من
مدينه خان يونس حيث تتمركز اعداد كبيره من
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في تلك
المنطقه وسط محاولات من قبل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه للتصدي لاي توغل اسرائيلي عبر
هذين المحورين سواء من منطقه الكتيبه او
المحطه باتجاه منطقه البلد او من منطقه
بير عيه وقز الجار والدخول الى المدينه من
المحور الجنوبي الغربي من مدينه خانيونس
طيب يبقى السؤال عن اعداد الشهداء والجرحى
والمنزل الذي تم قصفه هذا المساء والذي
اشرنا اليه في بدايه هذا
الخبر حتى هذه اللحظه وما تمكنت طواقم
الاسعاف والمواطنون ايضا الذين اتوا سيرا
على الاقدام حاملين الاصابات الى مجمع
ناصر الطبي وعبر دراجات الناريه ووصول
ثلاثه من الشهداء بالاضافه الى عدد من
الاصابات والحديث يدور عن عدد اخر من
المفقودين بين ركام هذا المنزل الذي دمرته
طائرات الاحتلال وصواريخها على رؤوس
ساكنيه دون سابق انذار فرق الانقاذ وفرق
الدفاع المدني وايضا طواقم الاسعاف تمتلك
امكانيه
بسيطه جدا للغايه لا تساعد في هذا الليل
المتاخر وفي ظل القصف المدفعي الكثيف
وايضا الغارات الجويه للبقاء في مكان
المكان المنزل المستهدف لانتشال جثامين
الشهداء واخراج ايضا انقاذ الجرحى ان كان
هناك جرحى بين ركام هذا المنزل الذي دمرته
صواريخ طائرات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
على رؤوس ساكنيه في هذا الوقت المتاخر من
الليل حسن